الارجنتين تفوز على كرواتيا وملامح نهائي
المونديال تتضح وكما اعتدنا اليكم بعض
الارقام والاحصائيات بعد هذا الانتصار
الارجنتين في نهائي المونديال للمره
السادسه في التاريخ وهو ثاني اكثر فريق
يصل هذا الدور بعد المانيا التي شاركت في
ثمانيه نهائيات من قبل جوليان الفرز هو
اصغر من يسجل هدفين في نصف نهائي
المونديال بعد الاسطوره البرازيليه بيليه
في كاس العالم عام
1958 ليو ميسي هو الاعلى تسجيلا للارجنتين
في كاس العالم برصيد 11 هدفا متخصصي
المواطنه
ميسي يصبح اللاعب الاول الذي يسجل ويصنع
خلال اربع مباريات متتاليه منذ نسخه عام
1966 ميرسي يصبح ثاني لاعب في تاريخ
المونديال يحقق جائزه افضل لاعب في اربع
مباريات في نسخه واحده والجديد بالذكر ان
اول من حقق ذلك كان ميسي ايضا في مونديال